Ci sono delle cose che a Natale non cambiano mai, per esempio comprare queste cravatte di merda
Oppure comprare quelle orrende cartoline natalizie da regalare ai parenti. Ma non sarebbe ora di cambiare?
Non sarebbe ora di guardare al futuro e di usare la tecnologia per sopperire alle nostre mancanze?!
Direi di sì ed è per questo che quest'anno vi propongo la mia cartolina virtuale
Perché fermarsi a scrivere auguri quando puoi raccontare una perfetta storia di Natale?
E la nostra storia come ogni anno inizia...
Eh beh...
A..a Natale
Ma, in particolare, al cinema con l'uscita dei rispettivi cinepanettoni di Christian De Sica e Massimo Boldi
Ovviamente anche quest'anno accompagneranno le nostre feste con un po' di risate, un pizzico di spensieratezza
..un pochino di vomitino anche, un leggero disgusto
Ma quest'anno, non saranno "solo" due cinepanettoni
Ce ne sarà anche un terzo, che si chiama: SUPER vacanze di Natale
Santo cielo quando ricorri al "super" davanti al titolo le cose si mettono male
E che cos'è esattamente "Super vacanze di Natale", qual è la sua trama?
Beh
Non ne ha una
Super vacanze di Natale è un mega montaggio delle scene migliori di tutti I cinepanettoni
No, non sto scherzando! Esce al cinema questa cosa qui
Tu devi uscire di casa
vestirti abbondantemente perché fa freschino verso Natale
cercare parcheggio
entrare nel cinema e
pagare dei soldi e io sto letteralmente
morendo dalla curiosità di vederlo.
Questa cosa è molto natalizia, mi scalda il cuore per vari motivi ma il primo motivo è perché il trailer di "Super vacanze di Natale" finisce con scritto
"Regia di Paolo Ruffini"... Regia... Secondo perché il produttore Aurelio De Laurentiis a quanto pare
non è che l'abbia spiegato benissimo a De Sica e Boldi cosa avrebbe voluto fare perché Boldi
ha minacciato legalmente di togliere il film e De Sica invece De Sica mi ha stupito perché lui ha detto semplicemente "Non c'era bisogno
Non c'era bisogno perché se vuoi vedere delle clip di Christian De Sica in Vacanze di Natale
basta cercarlo su Youtube.
Christian
Bravo! Certo poi l'età ha preso il sopravvento perché ha detto "Basta cercare the best of Christian De Sica"
e io mi chiedo perché in inglese Christian. Tra l'altro il signor De Sica ha fatto questa intervista durante la presentazione
Del suo nuovo album
musicale natalizio
Oddio
"Merry Christian"...
L'ho capita! Io ancora non riesco a concepire che De Sica stesso abbia detto andatevela a vedere su Youtube questo è uno
squarcio generazionale pazzesco perché veramente un sacco di gente
ha già fatto dei montaggi su Youtube,
è una roba pazzesca da vedere al cinema infatti mi sono immaginato seduto in sala a vedere il film
partire con un logo da gamer quello da quattordicenne
con i bassi fortissimi e poi far partire la clip. Ma non è finita qua ovviamente
io ne volevo sapere di più di questo "Super vacanze di Natale"
Quindi mi sono andato a vedere le interviste di Ruffini e in queste interviste lui
ha detto di tutto, ha detto di essere un
superfan dei cinepanettoni, ha detto che Massimo Boldi è il Ted italiano.
"È come pensare che Ted
è nudo, ma non ci pensi, è un orso! Ecco Boldi è uguale, Boldi è un Ted scorretto del cinema italiano"
Nooooon ho capito...
E poi
non una, ma due ciliegine natalizie per questa cartolina.
È riuscito a dire:
"Cioè il paradosso è che questi film sono sempre stati anche un pochino
accusati e tacciati di volgarità".
E seconda ciliegina queste interviste
dove cercava in tutti I modi di giustificare il montaggio che ha portato al cinema
Lui le ha fatte con addosso...
la maglietta di Fantozzi!
Abbiamo finalmente toccato il fondo del cinema italiano
Sììììììììììì!
Ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi
sono molto contento di questo traguardo grazie mille, grazie mille a tutti
Io andrò a vederlo il film, mi raccomando, andrò a vederlo tutto quanto perché sono
stra-curioso, noi dobbiamo essere testimoni di questa cosa nella storia italiana, dobbiamo essere testimoni
del cinema italiano per il primo montaggione al cinema
Ruffini io ti aspetto
Lo voglio vedere e ne riparleremo. Ne riparleremo sicuramente, grazie mille e buon Natale a tutti!